へへ
だいぶ片目が隠れてきたぞ(ドヤ)
ふふふんっふふ~(^^♪
マドマゼール　日本のみんな
ワインのことは何も知らない。。。
伝説のソムリエ
♪~
私は今回コンビニに売っていたワインを全部買ってきたぁ
価格なんとぉ
３５，０００円！！
フッフウゥゥゥゥウ~~↑↑↑
これだけの量があると重すぎてコンビｎ…
わああああぁぁぁあ
私ワインには興味があるんです
むかし　　イタリア～ノにフラペチーノしたとき
とある白ワインを飲んだことがあります
その白ワインが
とてもとても美味しかったのでぇす
でもmeはワインの知識が全然なぁい
今回なのでとりあえず
コンビニに売ってたワイン全部集めてみました
この全種類のワインを１つにすると
(ガンッ)トレビア～
あ　いた
トレビア～～ンな味わいになるのではないかなと思いました
ＣＨＵ★
(すぅーー)
はぁ(白目)
(すぅーーー)
はぁぁ(変態)
(すうぅぅーーーー)
はああ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”(未確認物体)
ｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐｐ
ゴクッ
あ”
に”か”い”
至極の味わい
彼らはいろんな地方から来ているわけです
あなたはフランスのペイッドク地方からきたんですね
あなたは
あなたは，なんとスペインから来てる
あなたはフランスから来てますねぇ
世界各国のワインの味を１つにまとめたら
どんな極上なワインができるの……
(シュッシュ)
(バサぁ)
今、予知(よっち)したぜ？
今回はシンプルに全部のワインを１つにして
飲んでみようと思います
CHU☆
いやぁ　値段はほんとピンきりだねぇ
３０００～３００円
んｍｍ～
遊戯王カードと同じ相場だぁ
では早速混ぜていくよ
パチっ☆
この中にいれていくよ
VELLUTO
ミートスパゲッティとハンバーグと相性がいいです
マジふつーに飲みてぇわ。
ふつーにミートハンバーグとスパゲッティで飲みたい
あー
なるほど
すっぱいな
お酒は二十歳になってからだ
Z☆O
おいしい
たぶん１摘ぐらいでいいんだよな，
ほんのちょっびっとだけいれますね
ほい
せんしん　どるじぇぶりまべぇーる
甘口のワインだって
おおぉーーっと！！
君の涙のみたいだ♡
ぅあー　すっげーうめぇわ　コレ
これマジ一気飲みできるくらい美味しかった
これは高かった気がするなぁー
とれーすさんぐれでっとろ
こういう仕様なのはたいてい高いっていう奴なんすよね
スペインで採れたみたいです…
こういう類なのは　高いのは間違いねぇぜ
でも大事なのは値段じゃない……
君との時間さ(鳥肌注意)
っおおぉ～
※とか言っているけど彼はコレ何も分かっていない顔である
君の瞳も果実のようだ(吐き気注意)
いただきマックスむらい(怒られるぞ…)
ＰＯＮ★
うーーーーーー☆！！！(一応成人男性である)
俺も君の心の栓を
開けてあげたいものだ(グロ注意)
っああぁ～
シンプルにうまいやつだ
とぅとぅとぅとぅるとぅるとぅるとぅるとぅ～　　　ちゅるるるるるるぅ～る（酔いスタート☆）
ゴクっ
U★Ｍ☆Ａ★Ｉ
っあー
これ待ってムズイ
PON
ぁおっ!!!!!
だからなんでこうなるのさ
俺にや，いつまで経っても飲まれにゃいよ
え，え，いやいや，そんなことないよ
きっとはじめんならとってくれる
よぉ～～し!!!　まかせろぉぉ!!!
ＰＯＮ↑↑
ああ～
いや　さぞかし美味しいことでしょう
これだけ頑張ったぁashhshsh
〇△▢✖∴§ΦΨ
いただきます
はじめのこの顔は
いまいち
味の違いが
わからないときである
ＰＡＮ↑↑
( ﾟДﾟ)
なんかもうねぇー
辛口も甘口も美味しく感できちゃったわけよ
てんしーぶるごじぶれきそろっそ
きほん　赤わいんにおおいのね
もぉ～💛
ああぁあ!!!
これは飲みやすそうだなぁー!!!
アスパラのゆうびんばっくばきあとまとぱすたにすごいあうってかいてあるから
あ～いいな～　アスパラのトマトパスタ巻き食べたいなぁ～
っあーーーー
うまいなぁ
ここからはぁ～ちょっと高そうな奴たちが多いのでぇー
これを使わないと開かないやつばっっかりヽ(`Д´)ﾉﾌﾟﾝﾌﾟﾝ
一気にたたみかけるお
全部開けましょう
ひとまずこれをこう
やべぇ　　もうすぐ誕生日だぁ～
もう２４　　ちょーあせるわー
あい　あい　よし
飲むぞおおお↑↑
グビっ×４
ごじょれーぬーぼはちょっと多めに飲んでもいいのかもしれないね
っあー　　すげー
やっぱ酸味のレベルがちがう
これが１番高そうだなぁー
ぱらしおでるこんでぐらんせれるば
わあ、、すごい　　２００９年モデルだあ、、
結構むかしから　みんなつくってたんだねぇー
カンっ
ありがと♡
グビグビっ
微妙。
おぉけぇい
はあい　というわけですべてのワインが入りましたあ
こちらがコンビニに売っている全部のワイン集めた最強のワインです
これが美味しいかどうかはわかんないけれども
ひとまず確実にいろんな風味がまざっているわけよ　　この中には。
高いワインもあれば　安いワインもある
美味しいワインもあれば美味しくないワインもある。
世界には良いやつもいれば　悪いやつもいるよお!!!
でもなあ!!!
みんなまとめて人間じゃねえかよぉ!!!
う…うふ…
じゃあ、さっそく飲んでみるね☆彡
世の中の便利を追求したコンビニエンスストア
いただきましょう!!!
世界のみんな
乾杯
ウホウホ
うまい!!!!!!
バンッ